SPEAKER: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to another amazing
"Talks at Google" event.
It doesn't take a
very detailed search
to see that the news
headlines these days are
rather troubling on the
international front.
We're seeing in many
cases an assault
on the international system--
50 years of peace and prosperity
from things like the European
Union to NATO--
and where do we
stand with all that?
What is the impact on
governments on corporations?
Today we're very
thrilled to have
Bob Amsterdam with us today
to talk about this very issue.
Bob is an international lawyer
specializing in corporate law
and also advising governments.
His career has been very
storied across a dozen countries
from Asia, Africa,
Europe, and Latin America,
and today he's here to
talk about disruption
in the international
system, arguing
that the political
pressure being applied
against the judicial systems
and prosecutors today
have resulted in a crisis
of legitimacy that's
weakened institutions.
So we'll start out by
talking a little bit
about the current
situation and then
some thoughts for the future.
And with that, thank you very
much and welcome to Google.
ROBERT AMSTERDAM:
Thanks very much.
Thank you very much.
I'm going to be talking
today about essentially how
corporations can thrive in the
upcoming trade wars and issues
that have been raised by the
rise of populism in the world,
not just in the United States
with the Trump election,
but in Europe with Brexit
and now potentially Frexit.
In the Philippines with Duterte.
In Mexico.
We've seen this rising
tide of populism,
and of course, now, six
weeks after the election,
we're seeing a tremendous
level of discourse
in the United States
concerning Russia's impact
on American politics.
And I thought, given
how current that topic
is, that we might take a
few minutes to discuss it.
I have spent most of
my life studying Russia
and was involved in the
Yukos case in Russia in 2003
when the Russian government
essentially stole
the assets of Yukos
and jailed its founder.
And I was working with him and
one of the defense team for him
for many years and was arrested
in Russia in September of 2005.
And one of the things
that has hit me
about the present scenario
in the United States
that seems to have
been missed by many
is that the Trump
agenda substantively is
a mirror of the Putin agenda.
And not only does it go against
Americans' policy of open door
capitalism, but it goes against
what this country has defined
as its national
interests, particularly
the embrace of Nigel
Farage, the embrace of those
who want to see the EU split.
This is from page one of
Vladimir Putin's gamebook.
This is what he was trying to
do with his energy diplomacy.
This is what he's been trying to
do with the invasion of Ukraine
and the seizure of Crimea.
And in my view, the attack on
the American electoral system
that took place was
never meant to be
an attack that would actually
place Donald Trump in power.
It was meant to
be an attack that
would undermine not
only Hillary Clinton,
but the political institutions
of the United States.
And to that extent, it's
been a tremendous success.
We are seeing the United
States and the Democrats using
this series of
incidents in particular
to move very aggressively--
today, demanding the
resignation of Sessions,
over the last number of weeks
working very hard in a manner
reminiscent of the Tea
Party to, if you will,
de-legitimize the
Trump administration
at its earliest point.
But let's talk about
some of Trump's policies
because firstly his
massive army build up,
again, copies exactly
what Vladimir Putin has
done in Russia.
The xenophobic attacks, the
immigration attacks, again,
are almost identical.
The issues with respect
to NGOs and the media--
in fact, going so far
as to call the media
the enemy of the
people is actually
to use a term really framed by
Stalin in the '30s and hearkens
back to some of
these commonalities.
And what is perhaps
most disturbing and most
did de-legitimizing is the
lying, the seeming inability
to capture reality, but
when you have studied Russia
for a long time, you understand
that the lying cynically
can mean something very
much more than that.
There's a recent book that came
out, "Black Wind, White Snow--
The Rise of Russia's
New Nationalism."
And there is a quote from
that book that is, I think,
really important to read in
terms of the Putin mindset.
Quote, "Putin has
correctly surmised
that lies unite rather
than divide Russia's
political class.
The greater and more
obvious the lie,
the more his subjects
demonstrate their loyalty
by accepting it
and the more they
participate in the great
sacral mystery of Kremlin power
by believing it."
Hannah Arendt in "The
Origins of Totalitarianism"
stated "one could
make people believe
the most fantastic
statements one day
and trust that if
the next day they
were given irrefutable
proof of their falsehood
they would take
refuge in cynicism.
Instead of deserting the
leaders who had lied to them,
they would protest that
they had known all along
that the statement
was a lie and would
admire the leaders for their
superior tactical cleverness."
Make no mistake that
this constant absence
of the truth from the White
House, unless it is corrected,
is extraordinarily
corrosive, but also
a mimic of some of
Vladimir Putin's most
significant tactics
in having truly
destroyed most of
Russian civil society
in the period that dates from
2003 and the seizure of Yukos.
The economic
nationalism, however--
the economic nationalism
both of Putin's Russia,
which you can understand
because Putin's Russia
is an economy that is based
on the extractive industries.
Putin's Russia is
an economy where
there must be a constant
mobilization against the other,
whoever that other may be, in
order for Mr. Putin to stay
in power.
People often don't realize
that the real central node
of Russian foreign policy
isn't geopolitics alone.
It is mobilizing
the domestic elite
to pursue a foreign outcome.
That was one of the major
drives behind the Syrian attack.
So these substantive
similarities
between Trump and Putin
need to be assessed
with the same rigor
and seriousness
that we are attempting to
piece together what happened
in terms of the collusion.
For one, I'll say that tracing
this issue of collusion,
I think, is less significant
than focusing on Trump's
policies and behavior.
I think, frankly, the Democrats
are making a strategic error
in going too far into this
before a lot of hard evidence
has been discovered.
And I think in political
campaigns and political issues
you are constantly
dealing with momentum,
and there's a tremendous
danger in this particular case
that, if the smoking gun is not
found, the Democrats will have
taken an early and very
dangerous situation
and made it so that
their future attacks will
be less significant,
less important,
because remember,
up until today,
outside of the issue
of immigration,
most of the attacks have
followed about Russia.
We haven't spoken about China.
We haven't spoken about the
environment, the Arctic.
We haven't spoken about
entitlements and equality.
We haven't really
focused because there
hasn't been any
substantive legislation yet
on issues such as the
nuts and bolts of where
health care is going.
But outside of the parameter
of Russia and the United States
today, one of the things I want
to mention I think is important
is what I call the
presumption of regularity.
So often when we
talk about Russia
or when we talk about China,
we presume that these countries
and governments operate
the way our own does,
and that's just not the case.
When you're working
internationally,
either corporately or
as a lawyer on behalf
of a client, one of the most
important things you have to do
is disaggregate the power
centers within the country
with which you are engaged.
There is no such thing, in many
ways, as Russia in the sense
that, if you're trying
to intelligently analyze
where power is, you need
to analyze the people
around Vladimir Putin.
We're the real sources
of strength and weakness.
And in Russia's case, you
have to follow the money,
because in so many countries,
it's the corruption
and it's the money rather than
it is the political ideology
that actually masks
or determines what
the next steps are
in trying to protect
your individual corporate
or your individual asset.
In terms of other countries
and other scenarios,
what we've been
advocating for our clients
is what we call a
corporate foreign policy,
and we've been doing this since
we set up that blog in 2011.
We've been talking about
the need for corporations
to understand that
in today's world
neutrality does not exist.
The image we have
of corporations
acting in a neutral
manner hearkens back
to an era of very
strong sovereignty.
Hearkens back to an era
when your nation state
would be the one to
fight the fights for you
with your particular
industry or area of interest.
That has gone to a
significant extent,
and it's been taken away by
a wide variety of factors.
Number one-- a lot of
international governance,
but number two--
the downloading of
governmental responsibilities
to private industry.
I don't think we fully assess
how important that's been.
From private prisons
to private armies,
the governments,
especially since 2008,
have been offloading many
of their responsibilities,
and they've been doing it not
only because of the budget
issues, but because of
the legitimacy issues.
Americans need to understand
that brand America is badly
wounded and that the
war on terror combined
with the economic
collapse of 2008
has horribly wounded our
legitimacy and our ability
to have a bully pulpit
in the world with respect
to critical issues such as
human rights and rule of law.
We are not believed in the
world when it comes to our role
as a pillar of rule of law.
We simply are not
believed, which
is one of the reasons Donald
Trump's embrace of Putin
has been endorsed by
so many Republicans--
because there has been this
drive for a powerful leader
with a real movement
away from the respect
for the political
institutions, and that's
tremendously dangerous to
individual corporations--
especially larger
corporations, such as Google,
such as this one, where, in
fact, governments are looking--
other governments are looking
for points of retaliation.
They are looking
for points or places
where they can
essentially set up
a hostage for American
foreign policy.
And one of the incredible
points of interest
in the Trump campaign and
now in the Trump presidency
is that the attacks on Mexico,
the attacks on Australia,
the renunciation of the TPP--
all of these steps seem not to
follow from a coordinated game
plan.
We seem to be pushing a
tremendous amount of legitimacy
away from the United States,
a tremendous amount of what
attracted people to brand
America, not just with respect
to the politics
of these demands,
but with respect to the
lack of follow through,
the lack of consideration,
the lack of competence.
It is a very worrying
sign that the president,
who is well armed with
serious experts on China--
that his first move with respect
to China was to court Taiwan,
and then within a
matter of a few weeks
to get on the phone
with the leader of China
with the quid pro
quo for that phone
call essentially being a
recognition of the One China
policy.
It is equally concerning that,
in welcoming Bibi Netanyahu
to the United States, he was
so willing to talk about a one
nation solution and yet
a few days later reassert
the necessity of a
two state solution.
These are not minor
issues that can be
bandied about by a president.
These are the most substantive
core issues around which
American lives have been lost
and billions upon billions
of dollars have been spent.
One of the things
that one looks at when
one looks at the
present scenario,
however, is the fact that, with
this present situation in terms
of trading blocks and in terms
of Trump's new philosophy
and new methodology of
dealing with the world,
that those corporates who adopt
some form of policy, who allow
themselves to some extent to be
disaggregated away from certain
of the government's policies,
may well have opportunities,
but it is a tremendous
necessity now
to move for corporations
to start adopting policies
and start accepting within
their own organization
the fact that compliance, which
has been massively extended
by American corporations
internationally trying
to deal with laws such
as the FCPA compliance,
has to morph into
policy, because one
of the other problems that
the United States has faced
in this loss of
legitimacy has often
been the willingness
inside the United States
to target political
prosecutions, prosecutions
such as many under the FCPA.
The Foreign Corrupt
Practices Act
is an act which is very long on
policy, very short on case law,
and involves a tremendous amount
of prosecutorial discretion
often exercised against
foreign corporates.
9 out of 10 of the
largest penalties
that have been given
have been those
against foreign corporate,
and this continuing
diminution, where,
in fact with
respect to the FCPA,
prosecutors understand that they
can go with what they consider
to be a credible case and
get corporates to roll over--
time and time again
that methodology
hasn't been lost
in other countries.
When the United States
started to push the FCPA,
some of the most corrupt
rulers followed suit.
Kenya's ruler, arap Moi,
used anti-corruption to go
after his political
opponents, and in Russia, it
was anti-corruption that led
to the destruction of Yukos
and led to the ongoing
level of corporate raiding
that we've seen in Russia today
that continues to escalate.
I think one of the
important issues that
follow from this
de-legitimization
and this change in
attitude is something
we've called the dual state.
The dual state, which
is operative in Russia
and operative in
many other countries,
is a concept which
relates to part
of the activities of
the state appearing
to be law abiding, appearing
to be based on rules,
and regulations, and
foreseeability, and then
part of the conduct of the state
being completely ungoverned.
It was a concept
that was designed
to deal with Nazi
Germany, where you
had this tremendous level of
judicial competence sitting
above organs such as
the SS, who would beat,
maim, and murder without
any issue at all.
That dual state, to some extent,
exists not only in Russia,
but in many countries
around the world.
The deep state, which is an
argument that concerns us here
in the United States, as well--
the deep state relates to those
people in the government that
are embedded within the
government, those people
in the government here and
abroad that are forever--
irrespective of the
particular administration,
that are forever
engaged in managing
the safety and security
of the administration.
And there are many
people today who
believe that the deep
state in the United States
is on the attack
against Donald Trump,
but our point in
raising it is to talk
about how both the deep
state and the dual state
are part of what
corporations need
to include in their toolbox.
You simply can't look at dealing
with foreign countries in a way
as if to give credit to
the topical explanations
or expositions, or,
as we suggest often,
simply allow international
arbitration or some form
of international
dispute resolution
to satisfy the needs
of corporations.
Those types of dispute
mechanisms often last years,
and with corporate foreign
policy you can be lobbying.
You can be disaggregating.
You can be focusing on the real
power nodes within a country
without that level of delay,
and often to everyone's surprise
you can actually litigate in
some of the most difficult
countries and come out on top.
I think one of the
big surprises often
is that, even with
tough cases, if you
are able in a country where you
can use and get out the media--
if you can use the media and put
enough pressure on courts that
are ostensibly
rule of law courts,
you can get a result. In
other countries, however,
it becomes extremely
difficult. We
represented a political prisoner
in Venezuela, an individual who
had unfortunately been dragged
by Chavez into a dungeon
for over two years, and
for that individual,
we managed to get a UN order
from one of these organizations
within the UN that
can provide opinions.
An order was obtained for the
release of this individual,
which the Venezuelan
court, amazingly,
after he had been illegally
incarcerated for 32 months,
allowed that man to be
freed only temporarily
and only on bail.
Unfortunately,
within a few minutes,
Chavez went on
television, ordered
the arrest of the judge.
The judge was arrested.
She was taken to a prison.
She was burnt alive on
the day of the ruling.
She fortunately did not succumb
and is still alive today.
The client left the court
knowing that he could not
survive one more day
in Chavez's Venezuela
and very fortunately
managed to equip himself
with a very small propeller
driven device, travel for three
hours over the ocean--
managed to get to curacao, where
we had a jet ready to take him
to the United States,
where he has now
managed to obtain asylum.
But these types of cases
and these types of hostage
situations involve
understanding and getting
to the point of analysis.
And one of the things I
always recommend to companies
is to understand
the criminal law
in each country in
which you operate,
because if there is anything
other governments have learned
from us, it has been the
misuse of criminal law,
not just from us, but obviously
from their own histories.
And you often find that without
the right criminal lawyer,
whatever may be your
corporate plans--
whatever may be the
corporate legitimacy,
when individuals
are taken hostage,
you have nowhere to run, and
one of the most important things
we urge is that, when
corporates hire attorneys
in many of these countries,
from a practical standpoint,
they don't look to hire the
guy who went to Harvard.
They don't look to
hire the sister firm
of the American firm that
has an office in Caracas.
They don't necessarily
look to hire
the people that speak English.
Rather they look to
hire the people who
can manage and navigate
the local government
and the local area enough
so that they can translate
for you what that reality is.
So when one turns to today's
situation, what does one see?
What opportunities
and what problems
does one see for the future?
I'd say, number one, the
prospect of not only a trade
war, but a fundamental
attack on the EU,
where the United States
is seen not as an ally,
but as an enemy is a
tremendous risk and burden
for American corporates.
Be very clear--
Brexit and the
manner in which it's
being handled by the
May administration
is no different than
the Mexican wall.
I think they've been organized
by the same contractor.
The British currency has
been depreciated by over 20%
relative to the dollar,
and the House of Lords
just yesterday
defeated the government
in imposing certain conditions
on how Brexit will take place.
We've seen real chaos in
the UK for the first time
legally, because, in fact, David
Cameron, when he structured
Brexit, was addressing a problem
within his own political party.
There had been no demand for
secession, so what happened was
we had a vote that some
believe was gerrymandered.
Then we have a situation where
England had just survived
one Scottish referendum.
Now it faces another Scottish
referendum, potentially.
In addition to that, the
UK and the rest of Europe
have been unable to
fashion a response
to this first massive change
in the political dynamics
of Europe in dozens of years,
which is Putin's ability
to keep hold of Crimea.
This is an existential
threat to Europe
that we in the United
States have not
grasped the seriousness with
which the Europeans view
this, nor have we grasped the
seriousness with which Russia
has taken its job of
disaggregating the EU.
The funding that
Russia has given
so many of the major
contestants in EU battles--
Le Pen, backed by Russia--
Brexit, Farage,
backed by Russia--
Bulgaria, backed by Russia--
Montenegro, backed by Russia--
Schulz in Germany, not sure yet,
but the Russians are playing
very fast and loose with
this issue of false news,
the propagandizing that is going
on throughout the world with
this false news, which is
something else that companies
in the information
industry-- and we saw
Zuckerberg's
manifesto recently--
which companies in the
information industry
are going to have to address.
Because with so much
on the line in terms
of what is being
disseminated and the levels
to which the Russian
government is
going in Europe, and the way in
which the Chinese government is
moving very
aggressively to pick up
the vacuum of
American leadership--
this is another
tremendous issue we face.
Far more serious than the
Russian threat in the future
will be the Chinese
threat both economically
in terms of picking off
countries for which the United
States does not have the same
appetite for engagement--
I can't even begin to
understand what's happened with
Australian-American relations--
but firstly we have the
this America first ideology,
this economic
nationalism ideology,
which is completely unattractive
to the rest of the world.
The war on terror--
the various wars this government
has sponsored over the last 50
years are not compelling
aspects of brand America.
Countries are not attracted
to other countries
who are constantly expressing
a message of fear and concern.
The government, the
president is continuing
to use the words Islamic terror.
Terror is not Islamic.
We are alienating a billion and
a half citizens of the earth
by talking about terror as
somehow being only connected
to Islam.
Timothy McVeigh, to the
best of my understanding,
was not practicing Islam at
the time that bomb went off,
and we can go on and on.
These terror attacks, as
dangerous and unsettling
as they are, have nothing
to do with a religion.
They have to do with the
attempt to seize power
and to instrumentalize
our media.
So our point is that in the
future over these next four
or--
heaven help us-- eight years
we have to hope that this
government establishes a real
deep understanding of the fact
that issues like the
maintenance of the EU,
issues like a strong
power base with Russia--
that these issues are
internalized and that--
yesterday there was an
important appointment.
Fiona Hill may join the
administration with respect
to Russia.
These kinds of appointments,
as well as his appointments
with respect to national
security and defense,
are all to be welcomed, but the
issue that truly grabs at us
is America is not
in a position where
we want to adopt
economic nationalism,
where we want to go to war with
our neighbors and our friends.
If you had told me any American
president would have been
able to alienate Mexico and
Australia as opposed to what
are the natural competitors
of the United States,
I wouldn't have believed
that was possible,
nor would I have believed
that in the case of what
happened recently with the
executive order regarding
immigration that Uber
would have immediately lost
200,000 subscribers because
they didn't adjust quickly
enough to the political
issue that they
didn't want to be seen
supporting the executive order.
It is this kind of
lightning-like approach
to policy as opposed to
law that corporations
need to embrace very
aggressively as we
move through these
very uncertain waters.
So thank you very much.
Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: You spent some time in
Turkey, as well, if I remember.
I was wondering what
your thoughts are
on the current situation
there and how it interplays
with Russia, for example.
ROBERT AMSTERDAM:
Well, I've been
hired by the Turkish
government to deal
with the situation
of Mr. Gulen, who
is an Imam living in
Saylorsburg, Pennsylvania, who
runs 170 charter schools
in the United States.
Those charter schools take
half a billion dollars out
of the US economy.
A percentage of
that money is then
taken into what it turns out
to be essentially is a cult
and then shipped to
Turkey to continue
to work to undercut
the Turkish government.
Turkey views Gulen as
an existential threat.
We have done a series
of investigations,
which you can find at
GulenInvestigations.com, which
I think fully demonstrate
that the Gulen organization is
engaged in a massive H-1B
visa fraud, where they bring
over individuals,
state that they earn 53
or some other thousand
dollars, and then rebate
that money-- a percentage
of that money, 15% or 20%,
to the Imam.
Then, in addition to that,
they engage in a massive amount
of self-dealing through
real estate ventures,
through crony capitalism
at its worst, where
Gulen-related construction
companies engage
in no bid or low bid contracts
where the quality has just
been fairly shocking.
And what we've
done is we've tried
to work with a whole group of
American parents and teachers
to bring this to
light in really the 26
states in which the schools
are located, and we've been--
frankly it's been very difficult
because the charter school
industry in this country
is a religious totem
for certain people
and many Republicans,
and even if you say
that we're not viewing--
we're not trying to argue
pro-charter or anti-charter.
What we're trying to say is,
here's a bad charter that
needs to be addressed.
Even if that's how
limited you approach it,
it is very difficult
because many people simply
don't want to hear
it, and this is
one of the things I'm
finding in America today--
is that we've really lost the
ability to hear our opponents.
We've really lost
the ability to engage
in real meaningful dialogue.
And there's a book
that just came
out called "The Death of
Expertise" by a guy named
Tom Nichols, and
actually there's
a quote in this
book that's just--
I think it just sums it up.
"The death of
expertise is not just
a rejection of
existing knowledge.
It is fundamentally a rejection
of science and dispassionate
rationality, which
are the foundations
of modern civilization.
All citizens today
believe themselves
to be experts on everything."
And it's one of-- if you'll
excuse me, for all of the good
that Google has done, it is one
of the unfortunate byproducts
of googling-- is
that people believe
that within a few minutes
of googling any subject
they've mastered it.
And certainly one of
the problems we've faced
is trying to explain
at the state level
from politicians, many
of whom have received
significant payments
from this organization,
that there's a very
serious problem in terms
of not only what
this organization did
during the coup, but what this
organization has been doing
in Turkey for many,
many years and what
they appear to be intending to
do here in the United States.
AUDIENCE: Really
what the prognosis
is for the future in terms
of corporations dealing
on this governmental level-- is
it a matter of banding together
to express their interest
in a confederation,
or is it better just
that they each have
their own, essentially,
foreign policy?
ROBERT AMSTERDAM:
Well, I think it's
going to be necessary
for governments
to once again attempt
to come together.
We're going to see
the French vote.
We're going to see the
Brexit negotiations,
but I think the
Trump administration
has to decide on
what its message is
and who its voice is.
I mean, we're in an
embarrassing scenario
here where the president
will say one thing
to the American public, and then
a completely different message
is raised in Munich
by the vice president.
I mean, you can't really
run a foreign policy
with that many discordant
voices at the highest level.
So if what happens is the
Trump administration starts
to veer towards a more middle
of the road historically
consistent American
position, you're
seeing an American economy
that is starting to pick up
in a major way, and
it may be possible
that after some very significant
veering to-ing and fro-ing
we get back on track.
We renegotiate NAFTA.
We realize that complete
abandonment of the TPP
and leaving Asia
to China may not
be the greatest deal
in town, and we come up
with some new methodology,
some powerful series
of bilaterals that would
save president Trump's face
and at the same time
keep us in the game.
This is a great country that
leads the world in technology
and leads the world, until
recently, in many key sectors
like environmental technology.
So I think there's still a
tremendous amount of hope.
There isn't a necessity for
us to be negative completely,
but we also have to
suggest to the Democrats
that we don't want
to have another four
years of a stalemated Congress.
And I think that's--
the message has to be given
to both political parties
that they're going to
be held accountable,
and as somebody who has
been ferociously attacking
on the issue of
Russia, I can say
that the level of
instrumentalization
of this issue of the
Russia hack really has--
the Democrats really
have to slow down or--
forget the presumption
of innocence.
You do have to understand
that logically,
if you're sitting
here looking at what
happened in the election--
I'm sorry, from my
perspective, and I was here
for most of the time--
if I was going to point to
anything that might have swung
the election, it
was the Democrats
forgetting their base, and
it was Comey and the FBI.
And I think a lot of questions
have to be asked of Comey.
If he was aware of
this Russia stuff,
it sounds far more
relevant than reopening
Hillary to have at least opened
an investigation about that.
And it seems shocking to me, as
does the Obama administration's
reaction.
Once again, when you talk
about foreign policy,
the Obama
administration does not
get five stars, and this issue
of how they've handled Russia--
they did to Russia what
Trump did to Mexico.
Obama insulted
Russia unnecessarily.
There was no reason to call it
a second rate regional power
unless what you want to do is
just pour gasoline on a fire.
There's so much that a president
can do by his presentation,
by his words, by his conduct to
show respect to other nations,
and President Obama really
dropped the ball with respect
to Russia--
and to be fair, has
dropped the ball in respect
to a number of other
areas, like Syria--
and has left has left Trump
with some real difficulties.
And the fact is about
Russia they don't
have to be a mortal enemy.
There's no reason for it.
I think to that
extent Trump is right.
Russia has to clean up its
act, and at the same time,
some form of face saver
can be negotiated.
The real hard point is what are
we going to do about Crimea.
How is Crimea to be resolved?
That is one of the key points
for European integrity.
As well as, obviously,
the expansion
that's going on
in eastern Ukraine
is incredibly threatening,
but one believes
that can be more controlled.
I think from a Putin
standpoint Crimea is probably
entering the realm of
the non-negotiable,
and that presents a real
problem because it's
around Crimea and
eastern Ukraine
that the entire sanctions
morass is based.
AUDIENCE: You've
talked a lot about what
the corporations can do and what
the federal government can do.
Do you have a charge
for the individual?
Is there something that you
feel like the individual can do?
ROBERT AMSTERDAM:
Yeah, I'll tell you
I think that one of the things
the last election demonstrated
very significantly is that
individuals can do a lot.
The last election
demonstrated it.
The march on Washington
the day after the inaugural
demonstrated it,
even though there
were far fewer people at
the march on Washington
than at the inaugural.
We all know that.
That was very
powerful, and I think
with the assistance
of the internet,
of media harnessing
technology a tremendous
amount can be done.
In fact, arguably
the Trump team did
a tremendous amount by
harnessing digital technology,
and the same team that
did Trump did Brexit.
And it's led to a lot of very
powerful and obviously somewhat
difficult outcomes.
SPEAKER: Well, thank you
very much for speaking
with us today.
We'll have a link to your
blog and site in our video,
as well, for our viewers,
and thanks for stopping by.
ROBERT AMSTERDAM: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]